trim the [ __ ] I gotta trim the [ __ ]
manscape or lady scaper manscaped my
trans happy holidays hey guys some a be
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen the
holidays are legit around the corner and
things are getting a little bit creare
honestly I love this time of year but
what I don't love is the laundry list of
chores that I'm somehow having to get
through in the next few weeks I have to
trim the tree I have to get up on the
damn roof and put the lights out I've
got to fight somebody off at the mall
just to get the last American Girl it's
not and don't even get me started on all
the crazy bake sales and cookie
exchanges and pot Luck's that I've
signed myself up for so when things
start to get a little bit hectic my
go-to dessert are these amazing
peppermint brownies they are vegan
they're gluten free and they're no bake
so they are totally finished pull off
when you have absolutely no more time so
let's do this
[Music]
first let's make some brands to a food
processor I add some pitted and date
scheduled dates and process them until
they start to break down then I add in
some almond flour some cocoa powder some
vanilla extract some melted coconut oil
and a pinch of salt and I period that
all together until it's nice and smooth
then I transfer that mixture to a bowl
and I added a lot of crushed candy canes
because it is the holidays after all and
I give it a good stir to mix everything
throughout then to an 8-inch square
baking dish I line it with some
parchment paper and then firmly press
the mixture into the baking dish
[Music]
pop it into the fridge for about 15 to
20 minutes and let's get anything
ganache I bring some coconut milk to a
quick little boil and then pour it over
some dairy-free dark chocolate give it a
good stir to let all that chocolate
melts and then add in a splash of some
peppermint extract now it's time to
decorate I take my brownies out of the
fridge and pour the ganache all over the
top
sprinkle it with some more crushed candy
canes as well as some red and green
chocolate candies
and then pop them back your fridge for
about an hour to set up after an hour
it's really easy to remove them from the
baking dish using the wings of your
parchment paper then using a wet and
warm knife you can slice them into
squares
[Music]
well guys there you go I checked one big
thing off your holiday to-do list can't
help you with the American girl but good
luck with that one
I hope you enjoy this recipe if
the thumbs-up leave
favorite go-to blasting the dessert
ideas subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time of hobby 50
bye
[Music]